que a entrar en esas aguas porque hay
una serie de excepciones históricas que
se podrían ese tema para el primer
título es este que lamento haberte
deseado la muerte suena a película de
james bond ya en este caso es más bien
porque los cantantes de este grupo de
diez son de montreal y son y eso hace
una pareja el cantante y la cantante
entonces y tiene un niño y pues a través
de estos años pude pudimos ver cómo
crecieron un pequeño grupito hacer
grandes shows en otras partes del mundo
y algunas son refleja refleja sí yo creo
que hay una que es bueno aquí no ha
deseado porque me imagino que tengo una
fuerte no su informa es para seguir
sería creíble que alguien diga que se
arrepiente de haber te deseo la muerte
que opine nuestros oyentes así que
digamos que es lo que piensan de estos
títulos de canciones 11 tiene las
expresiones por ahí va manejando a ojalá
te mueras
también sabe que es el momento no más y
que en ese caso no puede ser el enojo
entre niños me decía que te vaya bien
pasamos ahora las noticias que han
llamado atención esta semana luís algo
que te haya buena atención para seguir
en la misma línea de algo que decíamos
la semana pasada y no entrar en temas
más escatológicos lo que me llamó la
atención fue la brutal nevada que hubo
esta semana en calgary en alberta donde
cayeron no recuerdo exactamente cuántos
horas pero casi 40 vuelos para llegar
acá también así que no hables tanto de
los vecinos de que preparado
en algún momento se cruce con una
barrera y en el centro
aunque a mí no te digo 40 centímetros me
encanta
a mí también en la primera nevada
la segunda empieza a caer un poquito el
gusto en la 28ª aún no tiene y cuando
vas por el cuarto mes de nieve en la
nieve me gusta lo que no me gusta ese
frío intenso pero bueno es un frío seco
un frío seco sakhir honor aquello que
usted llama tensión me llamó la atención
y de manera muy muy agradable fue esta
distinción del premio nobel de física a
una profesora de la universidad waterloo
ontario la profesora de ese don a
strickland que además hay que decirlo ni
siquiera es profesora titular para que
veamos es una mujer bueno no empecemos
de cincuenta y pico de años ella recibió
el premio junto con el que fue su
profesor en una época por haber
desarrollado
estas es lo que ellos dicen a ver con
pulsos láser cortos e intensos para
decir lo que todo el mundo lo entienda
que llevó a esta famosa operación del
ojo con láser para terminar con la
miopía y otro tipo de correcciones está
ella detrás de todas y que se ha
utilizado inclusive para combatir el
cáncer cerebral que tenía el ex
presidente a nivel científico bueno
entonces sí sí sí sí fue un fue fue un
gran es un gran descubrimiento lo que
hicieron entonces pues fue honrada con
ese premio y lo cual me alegra muchísimo
porque es la primera mujer que recibió
el premio de física en 1903 fue marie
curie
y creo que ella recibió dos premio nobel
uno junto con el que era su marido que
haré y después ella sola si no me
equivoco y ahora es la última vez fue
hace 55 años entonces cuando uno empieza
a ver todas esas fechas empieza a
hacerse preguntas porque además sabemos
que las mujeres son las que más estudian
en las universidades son las que más
títulos reciben cómo es posible tres
mujeres en física en más de 100 años no
hay una película justamente sobre la
misión espacial que llegó a la luna y
que los cálculos serán hechos por
mujeres y que claro sí y además había
una negra sí sí
fue increíble entonces pues incluso
ahora el comité del premio nobel salió a
decir que todos aquellos que proponen
candidatos a los premios nobel dejen sus
prejuicios detrás y se fijen más en las
mujeres entonces eso me pareció
interesante es una época bien
interesante para las mujeres sobre todo
en este momento entonces pues
gusta muchísimo esa noticia y una va
dándose cuenta justamente de esos
eventos o de formas de vida que son tan
normales me acuerdo que un grupo de
mujeres planteó por ejemplo el hecho de
que hay tan pocas mujeres artistas en
los museos droid tantos desnudos de
mujeres en los museos de juanes es está
muy bien dicho muy bien dicho y
volviendo al tema de los nobel que
también es interesante porque hubo
tantas noticias sacaron el caso de una
mujer científica que hace 40 años
tendría que haber recibido el premio
nobel pero lo recibió su profesor y fue
ella la que había deshecho el gran
descubrimiento y 40 o 30 años más tarde
le dieron a esta mujer británica creo
que es un gran premio científico el
doble de dinero de lo que es el premio
nobel le dieron 3 millones de dólares de
premio por eso yo creo que fue un poco
también para el reconocimiento no de
esta gran científica que hizo ella donó
todo el dinero para
jóvenes que quieran iniciarse en
carreras científicas entonces que gestó
y también estuve viendo un poco la
historia de marie curie de soy de su
marido y inicialmente como es un es un
dominio dominado por los hombres le iban
a dar a él solo el premio nobel y fue él
el que salió a exigir
porque si no él se negaba a recibirlo
porque él sabía que era ella la que
estaba también al frente de todo este
descubrimiento si no era un poquito más
ella sí y en el ies más tortuosa la
historia de marie curie también yo me
acuerdo haber visto un documental y es
realmente violento lo que tuvo que vivir
para poder permanecer la ley es sacar
los fondos ella siguió una investigación
aparte murió por las rabias no tenía la
forma porque sabía qué había tanta
posibilidad de contaminarse con
radiación pero en un momento dado
directamente la sacaron
de los grandes centros de educación
exacto y así todo esto siguió siguió
siguió y logró bueno
lo que todos tenemos hoy gracias a ella
no entonces creo que el mundo también
necesita otros quier kuri es decir
hombres que reconozcan que son sus
alumnas o sus esposas o sus colegas que
tienen una gran participación en esos
descubrimientos y el mundo que sea un
poquito más justo no estaría de más
nuestra y además no si a mí lo que me
llamó la atención fue una noticia que
escuché a medias esta mañana pues estaba
a las corridas del aula todo pero hay
una investigación de la universidad de
harvard que habla que
el cambio de energía de la energía como
tenemos hoy en día a la eólica por
ejemplo no se sabe si va a producir
menos impacto en el medio en el medio
ambiente porque dice que más grave en
los grandes por eso no le escuché del
todo a la noticia pero más o menos es
que las grandes le daban ellos granjas
de los ventiladores para recuperar la
energía eólica contaminan con
temperatura el suelo
entonces es una contaminación también
están midiendo a ver si es si afecta más
o menos pero hay contaminación también
no hay ninguna energía pura que no
contamine y además de la contaminación
sonora que producen está producido que
en algunos casos algunos animales
abandonen la zona entra en esos
ventiladores que no están tan lejos de
aquí y aquí a 40 minutos de auto nos
encontramos con ellos yendo hacia el sur
oeste hay ventiladores de esos de los
que tubo hablan que es un ventilador
el y coordina se aisle efectivamente que
son las que producen con él con su
rotación la energía pero producen además
un ruido que en algunos casos es muy muy
intenso eso en algún momento se señaló
inclusive en las en las marítimas y que
ha hecho que por ejemplo aves emigrantes
y bueno y en este caso es hasta la
contaminación en el suelo por la
temperatura la alta temperatura que
genera
bueno estas hélices y qué bueno que
cambian pueden cambiar el ecosistema
también o sea que no hay hasta ahora lo
que menos con también es la electricidad
pero también contamina es más hemos
llegado a la contaminación que provoca
una una búsqueda de google si usted
escucha la energía que utiliza porque
cuando yo pongo acá
marie curie se conecta con 30 mil
servidores estoy haciendo con esa
búsqueda estoy haciendo funcionar 30.000
servidores y eso genera calentamiento o
sea que o sea que hay que volver a la
edad de piedra y que viene están
escuchando el programa de fin de semana
de radio que la internacional que nada
en esas técnicas café en nuestra edición
audio en nuestro sitio internet
escucharemos música de artistas como te
digo tiene terreno y también fue peligro
bien pasamos ahora una bruja que te
llama la atención a vos ser pues no
confesar si es verdad que no que ofrecí
por lo que me llamó la atención fue
honestamente
está
este salvarla el salvar el partido a
último minuto que fue justamente la
firma del tratado comercial entre esta
vez canadá y eeuu
y viendo de lejos pueden a eeuu
educación muy hábilmente dividió a los
contrincantes porque en un principio de
negociación los tres en la maestra pero
muy hábilmente dije bueno negoció con él
escogió el eslabón más débil más frágil
méxico donde desaparece una serie de
normas por ejemplo como el artículo 19
que protege a ambas pues protejan al
socio con menos con menos influencia y
poder de de por ejemplo de someterse a
leyes de un solo país y el lic
el negociador estadounidense explicaba
que eeuu no ibas a mentes a ningún otro
tribunal que no sea el de eeuu lo cual
en canadá pues defendió con uñas y
dientes porque es la única garantía
digamos de una cierta imparcialidad
porque basta ver el debate que está
ocurriendo actualmente a ver en la corte
suprema de justicia de eeuu para poner
justamente y legítimamente en duda
justamente la imparcialidad del más alto
tribunal del país vecino entonces
un país se someta a una disputa
comercial a un tribunal que básicamente
un sistema jurídico un sistema de
justicia que estaría en principio más
alineado en función de orientaciones
políticas entonces hace caer por tierra
la noción de justicia en el fondo
entonces este por ejemplo es un punto
que que por lo que se méxico no lo tiene
y ahora con canadá pues hay otra serie
de cláusulas que aventajan a canadá pero
que es que méxico no las tiene es decir
dividió para tener el plata jara más
grande de la torre al mismo tiempo
aplicó una táctica muy simple muy
rudimentaria esto que vos decís de
dividir para sacar provecho es la regla
básica de la negociación política
entonces líder y paras en eeuu pudo
llevarlo a cabo la administración tram
pudo llevado a cabo yo no creo que sea
culpa de la administración trans sino de
la respuesta que no se supo dar en todo
caso las presiones ejercidas por la
administración negoció primero con
mexico muy claramente aquí hemos hecho
y entrevistas incluso con gente de
distintos sectores de la economía y la
vida política mexicana donde ellos ya
daban a entender que esto iba a ocurrir
tranquilamente y desde el lado de canadá
la la sensación creo yo que permaneció
presente por más tiempo es que canadá
está esperando a ver qué pasaba al final
a ver si a último momento el señor se
arrepentía y cambiaba la idea se
transformaba en el hombre bueno que nos
reconociera los beneficios que por
naturaleza nos merecemos que nada pidió
esta negociación en esas negociaciones
de méxico-estados cientos que nos pidió
estar en la mesa no te olvides que lo
primero que se dijo fue que canadá se
sumó al acuerdo entre eeuu y méxico
que eso fue lo primero que se declaró en
eeuu cuando se conoció ni siquiera se
había conocido faltaban horas para que
se conociera todavía el anuncio de que
se había llegado a un acuerdo
efectivamente
cambiando cambiando para saludar a la
gente que nos está viendo permítanme que
lea maría herrera nos saluda con una
mano rené betancourt 2 en cordial saludo
al mejor equipo de locutores de radio
canadá internacional
después gilberto martínez ese saludo
gana las américas desde nicaragua y luis
balderas mis saludos y respetos desde
san antonio chile la gente que nos está
sintonizando por facebook si de
nicaragua que viene un fantástico un
saludo entonces gracias por estar con
nosotros sin escribanos que son dos
países de los que no recibimos mensajes
tan frecuentemente nos gustaría volver a
recibir con mucha más frecuencia de
otros destinos que también parecen
habernos olvidado un poco si hace tiempo
que no escuchamos nada de perú por
ejemplo de perú de no sé de bolivia si
había un oyente por ahí en santa cruz un
momento dado seguros de la época en la
que recibimos mensajes de oyentes en
español de áfrica por escriben desde
línea ecuatorial creo si efectivamente
si bien entonces para agregar un poquito
a lo que
jean-louis sobre este tratado de libre
comercio en realidad de parte del estuve
leyendo y escuchando un poco a ex
diplomáticos canadienses en eeuu algunas
por ejemplo decían que estaban
sorprendidos por esta este tipo de
negociación llevado adelante de la parte
de eeuu es decir cuando por ejemplo eeuu
obliga a canadá a que cachi canadá
quiere hacer no nombran a china en toda
esta negociación pero por ejemplo eeuu
se exige que si canadá quiere y méjico
quieren hacer un tipo de tener un tipo
de relación y desarrollar lazos
comerciales con países no como la que
decía que no son en la zona del área del
enorme emergente 9 emergentes solos y
sin economías de mercado sin economías
de mercado que hacían referencia china
tienen que avisarle a eeuu tres meses
antes de la intención si tienen de
iniciar conversaciones
este tipo de cláusulas que va dirigida
contra china porque en realidad en esto
ganó eeuu porque dicen que con esto
porque canadá aceptó tuvo que firmar eso
y méxico también ambos países aceptaron
esa propuesta de eeuu en lo que hicieron
fue trump lo que hizo fue impedir de
cierta manera que los mercados chinos
penetren acá en américa del norte y en
ese momento si es lo que decían un poco
los diplomáticos y otros analistas
canadienses es que en eeuu con este
presidente que está en este momento
actual ya no se puede decir que hay una
relación de amistad cercana como venían
diciéndolo hasta hace poco tiempo se
convirtió en una regla dice lo que trump
se equivoca él estuvo negociando como si
esto fuera un 1-1
llegará oa la creación de una fábrica
cuando lo que se está negociando es
entre naciones entonces eso me pareció
interesante destacar lo que lo dicen
pues los analistas canadienses en este
sentido fue
y también se añade a ese análisis el
hecho de que lo que genera lo que eeuu
ha puesto sobre la política ahora de
eeuu es la de la sumisión de los países
de la región y algo que cabe la vale la
pena destacar es que justamente un
reciente discurso
trump
recuerda y pone de nuevo sobre la mesa
la doctrina monroe
indicando que américa es para los
americanos justamente haciendo haciendo
referencia a américa latina
mike pence el vicepresidente ayer decía
que lamentaba la influencia de otros
países en la región que habían llevado
por ejemplo a algunos países
no a desconocer a taiwán y reconocer a
china entonces yo creo es eso lo dicen
los analistas lo dicen yo sigo mucho el
tema este sobre todo en si vice porque
hay análisis muy buenos si vice radio
canadá donde en definitiva ellos dicen
el enemigo de eeuu es china le tienen
miedo a los productos chinos a que china
extienda su influencia y lo está
haciendo en américa latina en áfrica en
otros países por esto fue que esta
negociación que obligó trump obligó
entre comillas porque si uno no quiere
no la firma digo yo aunque no sé cuáles
eran las alternativas porque también
trump dijo a nosotros también le vamos a
avisar a canadá ya mexico si queremos
iniciar conversaciones en fin
fueron negociaciones nunca antes vistas
esto lo dijo un ex primer ministro de
québec también y puede quedar en una
sesión muy complicada porque el nuevo en
el recambio organización ministerial que
hizo el gobierno del primer ministro
justin todo inclusive creó un ministerio
para la diversificación de la economía y
justamente de uno de los temas centrales
de la política canadiense es justamente
depender menos de eeuu claro pero si es
exactamente pero la política es el arte
de lo posible esto ya lo sabemos en un
dato por ejemplo que es que también tuve
acceso leí eso y que me llamó la
atención decían si canadá hoy no firmaba
el acuerdo de libre comercio se perdían
60 mil puestos de trabajos
inmediatamente en canadá eso para
cualquier persona que esté al frente de
un país tiene que pensarlo dos veces no
porque estás gobernando para tu país
entonces no hay hay entretelones que por
ejemplo cuando a mí se me escapan por
supuesto no tengo acceso a toda la
información pero fue muy preocupante
digo esta manera en que se llevó a cabo
esta negocio así como telón de fondo
además hay que recordar siempre el viejo
tema de que más del 70% del mercado
externo canadiense es totalmente de la y
de lados unidos eeuu con lo cual
se depende de un solo país en una medida
tan tan tan grande el margen de
negociación se reduce un truco
justamente ya había anunciado en el mes
del año pasado su intención de abrir sus
relaciones comerciales con china
exacto
comprar productos chinos sigue firmando
acuerdos con china y el resto del mundo
sigue yendo hacia la tendencia que se
encuentra entre nosotros se dedica al
asia que es la de una diversidad
comercial mucho más multilateralismo en
política y en comercio terminará
haciendo américa del norte la única
región que se cerrará en sí misma es
posible con eeuu está cerrando
completamente a esperemos hay esperanza
en noviembre de elecciones de medio
mandato ahí voy a ver entonces si los
demócratas logran revertir esa tendencia
y logran la mayoría en las cámaras sigue
no les falta mucho no y justamente en
esto
y todo este escándalo de esta gran es un
escándalo en realidad la la nominación
de un nuevo juez para la corte suprema
había una bandera de las mujeres que
decían nos vamos a acordar de esto en
noviembre es decir la nominación de un
muy impugnado juez a la corte suprema
que parece que es básicamente es es algo
que va a ocurrir este fin de semana bien
pasemos ahora a las mensajes que en
realidad nos diera gonzález nungaray
dice presente como siempre saludos
amigos de arse y así que salgan a javier
que siempre nos cheque no sé si estaba
en este momento trabajando en su taxi
que si está trabajando no nos puede
mandar mensajes por lo menos vista
no reclutado en méxico df sino minero y
hasta ahora sirven semitas
esos son los sandwiches que sirven en
puebla y que en las semitas un pan no es
un santo hecho tipo de samba
con un tipo de queso que es rico es una
es una delicia
[Música]
digamos bien digamos ahora justamente
con las cartas que dicen nuestros amigos
bueno podemos mantenernos dentro de la
problemática en la que estábamos hace
unos instantes y referirnos al tema de
china señala que eeuu es el país que más
interfiere en los asuntos de otras
naciones el mensaje que envía javier
gonzález nungaray dice ciertamente los
que ya tenemos más de 50 años sabemos
cómo se las han gastado los
norteamericanos a través de la historia
contemporánea un ejemplo es el caso de
la intervención militar en eeuu de eeuu
en vietnam por allá de los años 70
porque no dejó a este pueblo asiático
decidir su situación política interna
por ellos mismos
pienso que en base a estas
intervenciones de lineal le viene el
pseudónimo de imperialista a los eeuu un
saludo y un abrazo hasta montreal por
para todos en el castor cibernético
javier gonzález nungaray acá en
respuesta al tema sobre sobre fluyen en
canadá reacciones a favor y en contra
del nuevo acuerdo de comercio de américa
del norte dice comenta el rodrigo verá
yo rodrigo vega dice rodrigo el nuevo
acuerdo comercial entre los tres países
de américa del norte el reemplazo del
tlcan es un triunfo más para el
presidente de trump y su gobierno y un
fuerte apoyo político para su partido
republicano en las próximas elecciones
de noviembre y dice es asimismo un
triunfo para eeuu por cuanto el tratado
anterior resultaba poco equitativo y en
consecuencia desventajoso para los
intereses de la economía estadounidense
y más favorable para las economías
canadiense y mexicana esto lo dice
rodrigo vega yo aquí tengo un mensaje
que no tengo la firma
pero es sobre el tema dos tornados
golpearon duramente la capital
canadiense y sus alrededores y dice
verdaderamente fueron más bien causaron
un desastre estos tornados en el área de
la capital canadiense de ottawa viendo
los vídeos y las narraciones del
artículo periodístico de paloma martínez
de hershey saludos a todos en el castor
cibernético o canadá en las américas
café desde guadalajara bien algo más por
ahí louis un mensaje muy breve que envía
ismael cuyo apellido no tengo aquí sobre
el tema nueva amenaza para la
supervivencia del oso polar y maldice no
me sirvió de nada
[Risas]
acá tenemos la moda de los blogs en una
tendencia que sobrepasa las cripto
monedas y hay una respuesta de buscar
mesas a las que dice yo no acepto el
engaño y este es otro engaño al igual
que pretender que la gente piense que la
cripto moneda es un gran negocio si lo
es para los hackers quienes se volverán
ricos a costa de los inocentes engañados
sólo por posar de modernos y
tecnológicos ante sus amigos
cuando yo pueda comprar un pollo para
comer en la tienda de mi barrio con
cripto moneda
entonces pensaré dos veces hacer algún
tipo de inversión en estas en este
sofisma esto del blog chain es más de lo
mismo sólo que con más claves y darles
más dificultad a los hackers para
descifrar las claves pero hecha la ley
hecha la trampa como dicen en mi país y
estos señores hackers ella tienen
craneada la idea de avanzar uno por uno
las claves de este nuevo sistema
charlaba con la persona que viene del
artículo que me decía no sólo los hub en
los hackers los gobiernos si la tienen
la idea de cómo hacerlo aunque se dice
que esto va a ser anti hackers ya
sabemos cómo se maneja la historia eso
los señores hackers es muy respetuoso y
conozco también una persona que compró
así como hace como cinco o seis años
compró vaya a comprar un bitcoin tiene
tiene un bitcoin no evidentemente son
temas que hay que conocer a mi magna ves
me invitaron en su momento invertir en
la bolsa de valores en la argentina yo
nunca tomé la decisión para los números
al decir cuánto es dos más dos y ahí ya
me pierdo pero entre las diversas
personas que me invitaron había uno que
sin ser un hombre de negocios mucho
menos invertir en la bolsa y siempre se
llevaba su ganancias y evidentemente hay
que tener un conocimiento y grasa muy
fuerte para aguantar el estrés claro sí
que uno no lo tiene aquí tengo un último
mensaje recobrando sonrisa es un
programa de artistas canadienses para
mujeres marginales y yesenia jiménez nos
dice hola buenas noches espero que este
comentario llega a ustedes tengo 46 años
nunca he tenido mente adora buena me
recuerdo que siempre fui la burla de mis
compañeros en la escuela tuve dos
cirugías porque mis dientes nunca se
formaron y tuvieron que sacarlos de mis
encías más arriba acerca de la nariz
desde los 13 años he utilizado es
tendente a europos tiza y me cansé dice
mi paladar y encías que están muy
sensibles me da vergüenza reírme
como quisiera
que me sonrío y lo tengo
espontáneas y como quisiera que me sobre
se fue espontánea pero quisieras tener
una sonrisa bella antes de morir me dice
así que si pudieran ayudarme estaría muy
agradecida y le decimos a yesenia que
bueno lo que le decimos a todas las
personas que nos escriben por este tema
esto es particularmente en toronto y
para mujeres con problemas muy
específicos pero también hemos sabido
hemos tenido noticias de que existen
programas similares en otras ciudades y
inclusive en otros países así que lo que
había que hacer de xenia es justamente
buscar en tu país
de pertenece a dónde vivís ahora y ver
si hay algún tipo de programa similar
para ayudarte con este tema
en los últimos 15 minutos del programa
pasamos ahora los temas quieres
recomendamos para esta semana y turan
ahora nos hablas de una ong canadiense
que está buscando que jóvenes sin
estatus ingrese a las universidades y
también obtengan la residencia es un
organismo
llamado el centro del refugio que existe
en toronto su cofundador es francisco
rico martínez con él conversamos porque
él está al origen de una iniciativa en
toronto con el tema de estos jóvenes que
llegaron a canadá haciendo niños de
todas partes del mundo muchos
latinoamericanos pero también de otros
otros lugares que llegaron con sus
padres a los tres cuatro o cinco años
sin papeles que los padres puede que
hayan pedido el refugio o pueden que se
hayan quedado sin documentos y este y
los niños crecen en ese sistema sin
saber además que no tienen documentos
generalmente descubren eso cuando van a
la escuela secundaria
y eso sí él cuenta francisco el caso de
niños por ejemplo de chicos que van a la
secundaria que se inscriben en los
equipos de basquetbol y de repente
juegan también al básquet que lo invitan
a jugar eeuu con otros equipos entonces
va y le dice a los padres que necesitan
su documento su pasaporte y los padres
se ven obligados a decirle que no hay
ningún documento entonces es una
realidad bastante triste difícil no se
sabe cuántos jóvenes de estos hay en
canadá no hay datos oficiales pero
entonces lo que hizo francisco rico
ramírez fue él y otros jóvenes se
dirigieron a la universidad de york en
toronto proponiendo que se les permita
acceder a la universidad a estos jóvenes
sin documentos y que una vez que son
aceptados y reúnan las condiciones como
es haber terminado el secundario tener
buen inglés y pasar un test antes de
entrar a la universidad una vez que son
aceptados entran a la universidad y ahí
en ese mismo momento en que son
aceptados el organismo éste
va a inmigración canadá donde piden por
razones humanitarias que los dejes que
le den los papeles que le den le
permitan darle la residencia de estos
jóvenes y ya van dos jóvenes que fueron
aceptados en el marco de ese programa
entonces está funcionando me parece que
es algo muy interesante y valioso para
estos jóvenes porque además lo que dice
francisco es que los padres tendrían que
pensar dos veces antes de mentirle a los
hijos o no avisarles que no tienen esos
papeles porque les están haciendo pagar
a los hijos un problema que ellos han
traído entonces les causan traumas
porque cuando estos chicos descubren que
no tienen papeles les agarra un temor
tan grande de que la policía los agarre
los deporte otros países que crean otro
tipo de problema problema incluso de
salud mental
entonces se atención con esto me parece
que es interesante lo que están haciendo
y esta es la entrevista y bueno la
historia es mucho más larga en más
detalles pues ese día brevemente sigue
el equivalente a los gamers en canadá es
exactamente lo mismo son los soñadores
canadienses los
soñadores famosos en eeuu que trump
también puso fin a ese sueño de los
jóvenes soñadores diciendo que tienen
que irse de eeuu dea ya por supuesto son
cientos de miles no sé cuántos son no
pero son muchísimos
en algún momento hablé con alguien sobre
una problemática similar no recuerdo si
era la misma institución no pero esta
persona me decía que lo que ocurre en
algo en algunos casos no en todos es que
el trámite se demora eternamente los
padres no tienen nosotros los hijos se
ven sometidos ese es el limbo al cual
son sometidos esa parte del problema es
decir no todos los padres niegan la
realidad a los hijos pero sí es cierto
que algunos están esperando años e
inician su trámite de refugio y están
años viviendo sin tener los documentos
que recuerda que esta persona decía que
aún cuando los padres si se encuentra en
una situación legal no definida el hecho
de haber recibido durante años aquí en
canadá debería mover a las autoridades
debería condicional pero tendría que
llevarlos a encontrar una claro que
permitirles a esos niños que de todas
maneras
años viviendo aquí claro que puedan
continuar con su vida normal
eso sería lo ideal años después
sometidos a una situación que en todo
caso fue originada por sus padres y no
por ellos no no eso sería sería lo
condicionen condicional louis sería lo
ideal que les den a todos esos chicos
vamos esperan así no habría problemas y
luís que ese digamos yo diría no sé si
me equivoco luís pérez el más anglófilo
es en este momento filósofo
hablando no si tú has trabajado una
historia que pone en contacto a paul
mccartney con una ilustradora canadiense
en las últimas semanas paul mccartney el
ex beatle volvió a la palestra y sabemos
que porque sacó un álbum que debutó en
los rankings de ventas y debutó en el
número uno que no conseguía desde los
años 80 con su álbum está golf work
también tuvo una actuación privilegiada
en los rankings de ventas pero este
artista multifacético que anda por sus
76 años de edad no se cansa
probar instrumentos pintar etcétera que
conozco a alguien que fue al concierto
que dio en montreal quebec fue a los dos
un fanático y dice que está como se
encuentra en una gira mundial que debutó
aquí en canadá el fresón up tour con
shows que duran normalmente tres horas
de duración pero se está comiendo muchos
arándanos 36 canciones mínimo y bueno
tres horas de espectáculo
yo lo visto hace años yo actuar y lo
vino haciendo hace rato la dieta
vegetariana debe tener que ver con eso
wing y es también un luchador para
continuar la causa contra la violencia
con los animales
y ya esté aquí que este multifacético no
se cansa solamente de hacer música
etcétera sino que además ahora se ha
puesto escribir o se ha puesto no ya lo
ha escrito escrito un libro para niños a
partir de una expresión que utilizó uno
de sus ocho nietos que le llamó mucho la
atención y se valió de esa expresión
para usarla como título del libro y es
un libro que tiene parte de los textos
parte de ese texto escrito por paul
mccartney partes gráficos ilustraciones
dibujos y para hacer esos dibujos eligió
a una ilustradora canadiense que es
casting dorst que vive en ontario en
toronto más precisamente ella es
ilustradora desde hace décadas se
conmovió ante la elección de paul
mccartney para ponerle dibujos al libro
del ex beatle pero se arriesgó lo hizo
le gustó a paul mccartney los libros que
hace que flynn los libros perdón los
dibujos que hace casting y ahí está el
libro ya está listo esperando salir a la
venta y eso se producirá en mayo del año
próximo y mi libro se llama se llamaba
grande
i
el mexicano en argentino ese día
y está bien
leonardo tú has tomado otros temas son
siempre
eso no lo hacen pensar porque plantea
esa hora esta vez esta combinación entre
inteligencia artificial e inmigración
así es el citizen lab de toronto de la
universidad de toronto sacó un informe
diciendo que bueno los planes y este
proyecto piloto que debe el gobierno
canadiense para el análisis de
aplicaciones para acelerar los procesos
de aplicaciones de inmigración podría
ser nefasto para los que están aplicando
porque lo que ha hecho el gobierno es ha
tomado dos países con gran potencialidad
de inmigración como china y la india y
ha puesto a trabajar un algoritmo de
inteligencia artificial para hacer una
selección de
aplicaciones de los candidatos para la
inmigración y el citizen lab de toronto
sacó un informe con siete
recomendaciones porque ellos dicen que
está bien porque en realidad en el fondo
la idea es fantástica acelerar los
procesos para que la gente nos quede
prendida con un proceso que dura dos
tres cuatro cinco años cuando a veces es
mucho debería ser mucho más rápido pero
como hay una cantidad muy grande de
aplicaciones entonces el gobierno
canadiense optó por tratar de utilizar
un algoritmo y esto es lo que el citizen
lab dice que hay que tener muchísimo
cuidado porque el algoritmo aprende y a
veces no le enseñamos como corresponde
el algoritmo entonces estamos pasando de
costado cosas que quizás desde el punto
de vista humanitario no tendría tener
que tomarse en cuenta en un caso de
inmigración que una computadora no lo va
a interpretar de esa manera si uno no le
enseña y si uno no le dicen a enseñarle
una computadora a tener sentimientos
internos justin yendo con pasión retar
sentimiento exacto con compasión
interpretan sentimientos no pero sí
digamos que hay un caso particular que
tiene ciertas connotaciones y a decirles
a estos casos dejarlos de lado para
después hacer otro tipo de análisis a
una persona ahí lo haría una persona
pero eso todavía nosotros no nos figura
en los planes está solamente y este es
un proyecto piloto con dos países y la
historia es que querían ampliarlo para
poder acelerar las solicitudes de
ingreso y todos los trámites pero a
partir de este de este informe de la
universidad de toronto han puesto como
paños fríos y van a investigar y para
qué se puede cambiar para que funcione
de mejor manera cuando hablamos de
acelerar yo recuerdo siempre y cuando yo
hice mi trámite para venir aquí hace ya
muchos años en aquel momento postularse
desde la argentina el trámite en general
demanda aproximadamente entre nueve
meses y un año pero en china demandaba
entre siete y nueve años
entonces supongo que debe ser por eso
también que tratan de hacer acelerar los
de manera no usando recursos humanos
porque eso significaría también
incrementar la cantidad de gente que
trabaja solo para ese tipo de de colo
gratis entonces lo que han hecho es
tratar de no sacar el lugar a los a las
personas sino utilizar la inteligencia
artificial para ayudar a los agentes de
inmigración y parece que no estaría
funcionando la mejor me imagino que
podría ser el simple hecho de que al
final del día son seres humanos los que
elaboran los algoritmos claro que de uno
les enseña y si aprenden aprenden por
los casos digamos en otros en otros
elementos en otras facetas de nuestra
vida es genial la participación de la
inteligencia artificial como el caso por
ejemplo ahora se acaba de salir un
informe de unos don unos médicos de acá
de magill del instituto douglas donde
dicen que están utilizando la
inteligencia artificial y está aprobado
que parece que va a funcionar para
detectar antes de que una persona lo se
de demencia de demencia artificial de
tendencia que es el que lleva al
alzheimer bueno eso y también la
posibilidad gracias a todos estos
algoritmos que van aprendiendo a partir
de la casuística de discriminar qué
persona podría tener posibilidad de una
falla cardíaca en dos o tres años sea de
aquí a dos o tres años si eso sigue si
eso funciona es genial pero es complejo
cuando uno tiene que poner los
sentimientos como en el caso de la
inmigración si justamente desde un
centro mundos más importantes centros de
investigación en estos temas es el
citizen la app que ha descubierto por
ejemplo como arabia saudita está
justamente infiltrando los teléfonos
celulares de una persona que ha
denunciado denunciar los abusos en ese
sector es esa monarquía es un
quebequense si yo les recomiendo para
esta semana una entrevista que hice con
alguien
un amigo de radio cada internacional al
de usted quien trabaja que nada
tres libros que el estrado y lo saliente
de este caso es que él trae libros que
han sido escritos en lenguas indígenas
en este caso el zapoteco y también en la
lengua mapa que son lenguas m para que
son lenguas indígenas en méxico entonces
en el en el material en el psoe en el
sonido de este reportaje puede podrán
escuchar textos leídos en zapoteco
entonces el tema se llama pues indígena
mexicana en la maleta de arc dempster y
esos temas están en nuestro sitio en
internet
eres el punto sea bien amigos aquí
llegamos al final de este programa
estuvieron hoy con ustedes luis laborda
leonora chapman leonardo gimeno y
quienes al a ruffo valencia quienes
desea un excelente fin de semana y
estaremos de nuevo con ustedes en este
días y gracias por estar con nosotros en
facebook o youtube sitio en internet
y también saludos a los investigadores y
para la gente que lo festejé el lunes
que viene en canadá es el de acción de
gracia es para él
por eso se pierde el pago muchas gracias
hasta la próxima a dios